laughter's a social emotion
so we we're 30 times more likely to
laugh
there is somebody else with us than if
we're on our own and we'll laugh more if
we know those people
and we'll laugh more if we like those
people
why do humans laugh
we love to show that we agree with what
someone said that we remember
the same thing that they're alluding to
people will also use laughter to try and
mask other emotions people will laugh to
try and pretend they're not upset
or to cover up being angry or
embarrassed or in pain
people will use laughter to get other
people to do things
if you get someone laughing they will
tell you more intimate details about
themselves
there are two main kinds of laughter
according to sophie
the first is sort of spontaneous
laughter if you think about laughter
that happens and you cannot stop
laughing it can sound like this
the laughter just overwhelms you and
then you're just gonna have to ride it
out
that's quite a different kind of
laughter from the sort of laughter you
find in conversations which is of course
most of the laughter you encounter
and that sounds more like this
there laughter is really brief and it's
shared people tend to laugh together and
they laugh together in a very
coordinated way
people laugh at the ends of sentences
and that's
actually quite interesting because it's
even the case is somebody's having a
sign language conversation
where they could laugh all the way
through they don't they still laugh
together at the ends of sentences
so why can laughter sometimes feel
contagious
you can probably think of occasions when
you've been watching television or
listening to the radio
maybe it's been broadcast live and the
presenter
or presenters start to get the giggles
the award-winning screenwriter abby mann
has died at the age of 80.
he won an academy award in 1961 for
judgement at nuremberg
excuse me sorry abby mann also won
several emmys
including including one in 1973
for for a film which featured
a police detective called
if you chuckled while listening to that
clip here's why
it's called behaviorally contagious
phenomena which are things you can catch
from somebody else just because they're
doing them
you might have noticed this happens with
yawning it happens a lot with laughter
babies don't show any behaviorally
contagious phenomena
and effectively we teach them to so if
you look at
babies and parents parents will try and
make babies laugh and babies do laugh
and it's lovely
if the parent laughs the baby doesn't
join in if the baby laughs the parent
does join in
because the contagion is working and
effectively that seems to be the route
whereby we start to teach babies that
this is something that we do together
laughter isn't exclusive to humans we
know
that laughter is extremely easily
observed in other apes
so gorillas laugh chimpanzees laugh
orangutans laugh
and they laugh in a very very similar
way to humans
the main difference is that chimpanzees
for example laugh on an exhalation
and an inhalation so we just laugh ha
ha-ha-ha
breathing out chimpanzees do more like a
heart
sounds a bit like so chimpanzees use
laughter in a pretty complex way much as
we do
and it happens in the same situations
it's associated with
tickling with play with trying to make
play last longer
and it's not just primates laughter-like
behavior has also been described in rats
and parrots unfortunately laughter can
also have a darker side these
big squeezes that you do with your rib
cage when you laugh particularly if
you're laughing really hard
it's quite stressful for your heart and
your lung
and that can mean if you have some sort
of problem maybe with your heart or your
lungs or your blood vessels
you can put them under more strain and
throughout history
there are examples of people who have
died laughing
and i think if you're going to have to
go somehow probably going while you're
laughing
there could be worse ways luckily there
are lots of health benefits to laughing
too
you are more relaxed when you laugh so
as soon as you start laughing
you get a reduction in adrenaline you
also
get an increased uptake of the body's
naturally circulating
endorphins now that is because you do
quite a lot of exercise at your rib cage
when you laugh
it's exactly the same as a kind of
runner's high or the good feeling you
get after exercising
and interestingly that's true of
laughter even if you completely fake the
laughter so it does suggest
something to do with the hahaha
movements so
if you want to get your endorphins going
you can start by
laughing out loud and if you're by
yourself and have no one to laugh with
here's something that might help
oh my god
where did you find that
what is that
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video